when i was a kid in mexico
my father was like my best friend
and the day he left us a part of me left
with him
renato your father's very ill he really
needs to see you
listen not to be rude but i don't even
see him as my father anymore he never
came back
i'm not going to the u.s five days
before our wedding this man's the source
of all your issues
you have to go welcome to america
i just want to know what happened and
you will is this guy bothering you dad
dad meet your brother i sure what
my stories you deserve to know the truth
about why i never came back
so i put a whole trip together for you
both
my father's last wish is for me to go on
a scavenger hunt with a brother i never
knew i had
yeah hey there's another envelope in
here
it's like a clue he's weird i'm sure
he's not that bad
i'm gonna close my eyes do not wake me
up until we get there
start the car dude
what the hell was that
what is this place your father wanted to
come home to you more than anything
but fate has something else in store for
him
it's a claim ticket i'm getting married
in three days i'm done with this i'm
going home don't you want to know how
the story is
he forgot about me why didn't he come
back to us
this road trip's gonna give you that
answers
we are so close uh we're out of gas that
was your only responsibility
i love watching you freak out man we can
make ethanol to fill your car
is pure alcohol don't inhale it tie it
up
hey that is strong man you gotta go
completely white sand
[Music]
500 i've sent this shot
hey what happened they're just
overreacting just about me five hundred
[Music]
dollars
[Music]
you